so Snoop Dogg right what happened I love
it
he's been talking some mash [ __ ] oh okay
well mainly for this story we're gonna
focus on the Gayle King Gale Gale who's
guilty
Gale is from CBS this morning she's a
co-anchor and she okay so her own
network ended up tweeting out and out of
context interview clip where she was
interviewing Lisa Leslie who's a WNBA
basketball player she's a really close
friend of Kobe so after Kobe's death
Gayle King was interviewing her and this
clip was tweeted out by the network and
you even one doesn't like lit a fire a
lot of people here we go it's been said
that his legacy is complicated because
of sexual assault charge which was
dismissed in 2003 2004 is it complicated
for you as a woman as a WNBA player it's
not complicated for me at all even if
there's a few times that we've been at a
club at the same time Kobe's not the
kind of guy never been like you know
let's go get that girl or tell her or
send her this I have other NBA friends
better like that Kobe's me he was never
like that I just never see have ever
seen him being the kind of person that
would be do something to violate a woman
her be aggressive in that way that's
just not the person that I know listen
you wouldn't see it though this is
friend you wouldn't see it and that's
possible I just it's just I just don't I
just don't believe that and I'm not
saying things that had happened I just
don't believe that things didn't happen
with force is it even a fair question to
talk about it considering he's no longer
with us in Italy part of his history I
think
that the media should be more respectful
at this time it's like if you had
questions about it you've had many years
to ask him yes I don't think it's
something that we should keep yeah she's
so classy I thought they were gonna trap
her but she's well she's real victim in
the case refused to testify so it was
dismissed right she's so smart and
classy that's awesome I thought they
were gonna trap her Matt I'm so glad she
[ __ ] navigated that well yeah she's
good
so that was tweeted out and the whole
internet yeah what the [ __ ] she's
started getting death threats and snow
wait who's she all right yeah yeah yeah
we're talking I hated Gale after this
well but right but the best part of
those snoop did was she beloved before
this gift I'm expected in light I'm sure
she didn't have as much as a [ __ ]
media hat could be respected I see
frankly they're all the same to me okay
and in that the meaning is they're all
paid puppets mm-hmm
that's what they're all the same is they
all say the same all they're just
basically echoing what they're supposed
to echoes and it's not a middle and
thoughts and they don't question the
things that should be quiet they only
question the things that are easy they
all got paid like 20 [ __ ] million to
just basically exploit the black
community and do some shady [ __ ] so now
here comes snoop so this is his response
have to clear out the smoke first before
he said anything well he's getting
himself first did this and then he press
record oh that's awesome
here we go tutors Brandon what do you
guys
that's what I got we the worse we the
[ __ ] worse we expect more from you
cam don't you think I went over why are
y'all attacking us we owe people you
ain't coming after [ __ ] Harvey
Weinstein asking them dumbass questions
yo I guess they are I want to call you
one is it okay if I call him one funky
dog hit [ __ ] [ __ ] homeboys
reputation punk [ __ ] respect the
family and back off [ __ ] before we come
[ __ ] oh we were all thinking it funky
ass dog had business
he heard it oh my god I'm enjoying his
Instagram right now it's like back to
[ __ ] back yeah this one photo of
Oprah and Harvey and she's like look at
these [ __ ] best friends and she never
even called his ass out but she doesn't
even think twice to turn around and talk
[ __ ] to the males in their community and
I was just like what the [ __ ] that's
that's true like outside looking in I
was like I didn't even recognize that
but then that is [ __ ] true yeah [ __ ]
the Oprah knew Harvey everyone knew what
Harvey was up to nobody gave a [ __ ]
until afterward and then once the
fallout happen because of brave people
actually brave people
that's when everyone starts getting on
the bandwagon going like me - I agree I
read that together and you knew this
[ __ ] was going on yep so afterward
that's when there were multiple people
coming to the conversation like Roseman
Rose McGowan was like oh she's been all
about that yeah so she's pretty much
saying like you know Kobe was a hero
because eventually he respect like he
apologized and he respected women and
you should learn from him cook uh snoop
wait but he's guilty like that's [ __ ]
up from Rose McGowan too
just just to assume that he's guilty he
apologized like I mean that is a fact
that he did issue an apology to the
accuser saying like I'm so sorry that
you felt this way but that's not the
same to me it's not yeah
so anyway so Rose McGowan said something
and then also someone else a lot of
people are having to oh man like what
about all those other memes and photos
that he's been posting he he was
apologizing like when your mom tells you
that you know you were wrong now go
outside caption that too he said how to
talk with my mom thank you mama
two wrongs don't make a right
but what he initially talked about is
true and what he's apologizing for is
just the way that he reacted yeah which
is my
you're not yeah not what he was saying
yep sorry about that I think are you
sorry about the in the manner in which
you said it but but that's also it goes
to say like there's always a way to say
what you want or how you feel there's a
tactful way men there's like an
emotionally nothing's all addict and
funky dog heads and that is gonna be on
the next that was my friend like if that
was Jo or Bart I would have used the
same language I like to me that that
sometimes people just cross the line too
far all my friends and that's that would
you would you have used that for me that
like a funky dog hit a [ __ ] yeah would
you call someone that for somebody who's
talking [ __ ] on you yeah yeah what do
they say oh man I don't know something
bad just not nice I mean I probably
apologized to them first a million I'm
sorry you felt that way about stuff I
think you misunderstood Gia maybe maybe
okay so girl King said one day one day
you'll love me be very upset with the
with CBS and so she said this so she's
blaming CBS yeah so she said during the
course of the interview I asked
follow-up questions because I wanted to
make sure that her position or her
perspective were cleared yeah well they
were very clear when she said it's time
to leave it alone I thought that was
powerful and insisted that it be in the
interview because I thought it would put
a nice button on that part of the
conversation for the network to take the
most salacious part when taken out of
context and put it up online for people
who didn't see the whole interview is
very upsetting to me and that's
something I'm gonna have to deal with
with them there will be a very intense
discussion about it how about when all
these people are interviewing Harvey
Weinstein the red carpet about [ __ ] and
there's like hey Harv like what's your
new movie so cool like nobody [ __ ]
cares about that [ __ ] then right when
it's time to actually talk to these
people they don't they don't go like
here's the real questions they go like
what's the fluffy question I can ask but
then she gets pissed that the real
question got included like I don't know
well she's pissed that it was taken out
of context that's that's what she's mad
at you
Gayle King does not care when things are
taken out of context when she uses it
against other people she just cares when
it's against herself that's that's my I
mean
that's a human trade no we all feel like
that no like we all seen somebody be
possibly unfairly justly accused of
something and then that moment sucks to
be you
you know it doesn't really hit the home
until it's somebody close to us or us so
cuz if Oprah was on trial about this
[ __ ] like she is publicly right now
she's publicly on trial about this
Harvey Weinstein stuff how she tacitly
was cool with Harvey Weinstein King
would be like well you don't know Oprah
Oprah wouldn't be down for that [ __ ] all
this stuff I show it back Oprah I think
so obviously I was been back and Gayle
up oh oh really she went on the show and
she was like Gayle is not doing well you
know the network put that out there cuz
like that the whole interview had
already ran and nobody brought this up
nobody was up in arms on the whole thing
ran is because somebody isolated that
clip there like that's what everyone
does on [ __ ] Twitter man that's the
[ __ ] of Twitter do that to this all
the time so CBS this morning tweeted wmb
legend Lisa Leslie told Gayle King that
Kobe Bryant's legacy legacy is not
complicated for her despite his 2003
rape accusation I don't think it's
something that we should keep hanging
over his legacy and then they added that
clip I just showed you guys well let's
put it into in context what's missing
like to me in context Gayle still asked
that question and pushed on it the word
yes so it's like to me it sounds like a
bunch of [ __ ] she definitely still
pulled that thread and it's like alright
if she wanted to leave with something
she could have led with do you think
people are unjustly tying his past rep
rape allegations to his legacy yeah
that's the way you lead it to that
question because that's a tactful way of
doing it she did it as it as if she's
trying to track you right and get
something she has her own position
one of the sound yeah it was a trip it
was [ __ ] [ __ ] click generator
soundbite thing yeah
and that's what's [ __ ] up about it is
that it also she said I'm taking
innocent man who was acquitted and then
you say he's guilty anyway and that's
the [ __ ]
and to me that sensationalize [ __ ]
[ __ ] because you're trying to
capitalize in a [ __ ] trap during a
tragedy and that's why people were
pissed is because you're exploiting Kobe
and his family and then yeah for [ __ ]
clicks and if she didn't have the
[ __ ] right mind to realize what was
going on then she's also in the back
because she does have the the right to
say I don't want to ask these questions
yeah that's why I think it is a day
thing day as in like the media thing
because they just feed her lives and she
goes yes sir what at the same time as
much as I hate it she has the right to
ask the question I don't agree with it
the journalist journalist as a comedian
as a person as somebody with free speech
whoever you have the right to ask these
questions we have the right to judge you
the same way we all judge I should fear
for doing a shitty joke like you have
the right to ask these things but we
have the right to judge you back that's
all yeah but I mean the consequences are
[ __ ] real for asking questions like
that in the way that she did yeah and
how it turned she basically turned her
back on her own community it feels like
because of the way that she exploited
the tragedy yes yes and that's what he
came out it came out very exploitive
Lloyd she was trying to look for some
drama they didn't look like a police of
care yeah it was like this is drama so I
think that the attack was horrible and
like the chick said like you know Kobe
just died man it's like I was like why
the [ __ ] you asking me this
yeah